recommencez notre défilé avec ces
messieurs que vous nous commande d'être
en vie mais je vous signale d'abord
cosem le cem à donner gratuitement des
stands à des jeunes créateurs pour leur
permettre de trouver les fabricants et
on trouvera dans ce défilé
deux de ces jeunes créateurs que je vous
signalerais alors donc ça c'est l'homme
de toutes les couleurs et nous
commençons par façonnable qui défilent
devant la fresque d'hippolyte romain
alors lui il est vert jaune et rouge il
un blouson réversible et il a une belle
couleur de peau aussi derrière marquer
jean claude jitrois lui portent ses
règles sur les épaules c'est de l'agneau
velours bleu avec donc des aigles blancs
kenzo kenzo alors il est rose shocking
il a t-shirt avec capuche boutons d'or
et à moto vermillon et remarqué ces
belles baskets
le balmain jogging suit training de
bois-de-boulogne bleu dur et gris
de courrèges une combinaison jaune au
lin avec une blouse ont doublé de vos
draps et un parapluie extrême manquer
pour les pluies de printemps et voilà
non non non lise au golf avec sont ravis
daniel crémieux un cardigan écossais
bleu jaune et rouge en fait turquoise
le carven un boulot vers jacquard à
dessein oiseaux sur un pantalon de tarte
en rouge et vert
c'est bien steve
des gens regardent alors là on a le vert
les gens le rouge double et laurence
d'un seul coup avec une chemise sur une
autre chemise et à cache-poussière
marithé françois girbaud alors le
pantalon s'appelle zip août
ne me demandez pas pourquoi il est très
bonne entre jambe il n'a pas boutant sur
la chemise et il porte une casquette de
marcel fuchs une veste prince de galles
dans les verres sur un pool au vert
jaune le vert et blanc et le décès
s'appelle coup de pinceau de mini moi un
blouson de coton réversible sur une
chemise jaune orange
et le thème tribales
m
deux penaltys du batik violet avec le
nom
mise au range alors vous savez que
maintenant l'achat liste forte en dehors
du pantalon et lui il partait des
babouches superbe remontée d'agen
de cette note
imprimé jazz cet aspect cette chemise
sur l'hôtellerie perlon hyper large mais
aupic
l'euro vis à son qui est un des jeunes
créateurs acquis le sommes envers ces
fortes
un pastel abricots pantalons fuselés
poste échos les critiques et un pantalon
col de minutes
le structure toujours pastel amende
et abricots 6
un nouveau jeune créateur seigne a alors
lui c'est carrément le pantalon jupe
ça s'appelle une chute qui comme camille
une veste à col asymétrique
le plus d'un gratin arcanciane d'envié
et
et la chemise s'appelle éclatent vers le
pantalon court et très rock
deux vestiaires
à ce titre les comptes clairs prix du
lait
à carreaux et la combinaison chemise et
pantalon de rose art déco
avec les espadrilles a ressorti le me
giffard un smoking gilet avec partagas
est derrière vous allez voir à nouveau
fonctionner dix ans
decaux chine sato une chemise très long
des routes
avec une veste encore brûlante
émeraude pouvoir mais espère pantalon
pour elle et dans la jungle des villes
de chapeau
un jour un métier
découvert lors gandhi pour l'homme alors
que monsieur deux harmonies chemises
rouges anti chinois
chami zoom qui sort et pantalon en
organdi
certes évité la fota va troubler
merci france roche merci et daniel
vassallo d'abord si bien accompagné avec
sa team notamment ce défilé de mode mais
ça va nous obliger à changer notre look
nous les présentateurs avec le coach et
moi j'aime bien encore me dis pourquoi
pas mais oui bien merci faux